a business partner president Trump's
personal lawyer Michael Cohen has
pleaded guilty to criminal tax fraud if
Kenny Friedman is his name nicknamed the
taxi King for managing a large lead of
cabs will be forced to pay five million
dollars to New York State Paula Reed is
here with the potential implications for
Cohen and the president Paula good
morning welcome good morning while you
have Jenny Freedman is not directly tied
to mr. Trump his association with the
president's personal lawyer Michael
Cohen could raise alarms inside the
White House Friedman's guilty plea means
he could cooperate with government
prosecutors in state and federal
investigations that development could
possibly be used to leverage mr. Cohen
into cooperating in the special counsel
probe into Russian interference in the
2016 election Cohen is already under
investigation in New York State related
to his business practices his home
office and hotel room were raided in
April in a search for documents
including anything related to that 130
thousand dollar payment to adult film
star store McDaniels who claims she had
an affair with a president our hearing
for Cohen related to those search
warrants and whether Daniels attorney
Michael avenatti can join the
proceedings was originally scheduled for
tomorrow but it's been pushed back to
next week yeah it certainly seems like
Michael Cohen has a big decision to make
what are the chances that he won't
cooperate he needs to make a calculation
if he is charged at the federal and or
the state level he has to make a
decision as to whether or not he wants
to go forward through trial and gamble
on a possible presidential pardon that
the president would grant him a pardon
in exchange for not sharing sensitive
information about his inner circle and
his family but a presidential pardon
only protects you from federal charges
not any charges that he could face at
the state level so a difficult decision
for anyone are you hearing anything
about how he's feeling I saw an
interview with a close friend of his
that said the main thing on his mind
right now for Michael Cohen is his
family yes I have spoken to sources
familiar with his thinking and they say
he's having a tough time anyone in this
situation would be under enormous
pressure enormous stress and as we've
seen with other people who have been
charged in the Russia probe it's not
just stress on you it's stress on your
entire family and we have seen some
people because of that stress and the
financial pressures decide to cooperate
specifically Richard Gates all right
well really good to have you at the
table in-person thing
a lot